my name is Cassandra and I am a cosplay
gaming lifestyle social-media influencer
I'm Cindy
I emigrated from Taiwan I'm a housewife
right now
I'm Mandy oh and I am an actor singer
all-around performer I'm Jen I came from
the Philippines and I work in the
accounting department in a garment
manufacturing company I'm Dominic and
I'm an eSports coordinator I'm hung I'm
immigrant from Vietnam and I'm simply
since I was young I always knew that I
wanted to be an entertainer they kind of
let me dabble in my interests a little
bit you know like I got to play violin
and piano like every other good Asian
kid ever since I was young I've always
loved video games and then eventually
wanted to work at the games industry I
realized I wanted to be a performer in
middle school my dad used to tell me
that I should be a lawyer maybe because
I was good at lying
um but they wanted me to be that I just
didn't really have the inspiration to be
that and there was a an acting class in
middle school that opened up and I just
fell in love with it well my parents
didn't support me I knew it was with the
best of intentions and my mom's always
been a saint of a person I actually
ended up hiding the fact that I was
working in the industry as a contractor
slowly building up experience for four
years it's not really bad because I felt
like I had to lie and in order for
approval most traditional Asian families
know that the arts is not the most
stable income and traditionally in the
Chinese culture at least there is some
expectation to in the future take care
of their parents in return and the
likeliness of that happening with an
unstable income is probably not going to
happen
[Music]
no don't
not really I have no idea what my mom's
how did you I actually don't know what
is it well I really wanted to be a
lawyer because my dad was a lawyer
almost everyone in my family there were
lawyers and my childhood dream was
become a teacher I always want to be the
teacher when the Communists come they
don't let us go to school anymore so
that's why my dream to be the teacher
cannot be language barrier that's the
big problem for all the immigrants so I
had that problem too I cannot go to
school and how can I be the teacher so
that's why I changed my mind my mom let
me go to learn how to sell when I don't
have to sell and then I have a chance to
be teacher even though I don't make a
lot of money on that I opened a little
shop at home and I teach my friend even
though it's free first I'm a teacher too
I made a lot of sacrifices for my family
and my children they they know that
we were in an abusive home
so I have to take an holder the the pain
just so that my my children will be
protected and so like when we were here
their dad already passed away so I have
to raise them on my own I have to work
almost seven days a week just so for us
just so for me to provide for all their
other needs so I gave up the dream
it's terrible time mm-hmm we appreciate
that time even though it's not good we
learned something right because if we
know in the back the situation and we'd
not appreciate I don't know I was so
sorry I couldn't be the doctor or
scientists or something at least a
computer programmer it's okay for you
because I'm working so hard at what I do
but I'm so afraid that I'm not gonna
make it in time for you and dad to see
it as long as you you do your best and
you enjoy it that's what we want
I didn't know you had to go through all
that and it makes me want to be better
still not gonna be a doctor
but uh thanks to your sacrifices I have
this opportunity and it's not something
that I take lightly thank you so much
mom ah thanks mom
[Music]
you did good you did really good and
you're still doing really really good
thank you
[Music]